Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday, Monday morning podcast.
And I just checking in on Ya.
I'm just checking in on you seeing how your weeks go.
And that's all I'm doing here.
Just running my fucking freckled Yap for another 30 minutes of my God damn life.
And you know what?
You're going to sit there and listen to it unless you don't want to.
Then you can always hit stop. You can find another website.
You know, watch some porn at work. Pretend you're working,
put your right or left hand and your slacks, your action slacks. You know,
rub one out. Tell people later you got to lay off the glazed donuts.
Oh, come on bill that, that early in Jesus Christ.
You go with the, just joke that fucking early in this,
this does not show a lot of promise that was in under a minute.
The first just joke. You know what I mean?
That's like when you watch one of the, you know, quickest knockouts, you know,
and you're looking at the other guy like why the fuck did you even show up?
You know, I could've done that.
I could've gone in there with no fucking training whatsoever. What so,
and I could've got my fucking ass knocked out in less than a minute, you know,
although I wouldn't have the balls to then go try to figure out what I did wrong
and then come back to potentially have it again.
And that's what separates the audience member from the professional fighter that
gets knocked out in a minute. You know,
whenever you see that there's always that guy do it. I could have fucking done
really. You could have gotten top physical condition.
You Tub of Shit fucking sitting here. Who eats fried dough in a boxing match?
I didn't even know they sell it.
They steady know they sold that shit at a boxing match. You Fat. Fuck.
What do you think? What w what'd you find that? Huh?
He's like some fucking food whale. You know like when, when the, when the, um,
degenerate gamblers show up and they get flown in and they get this giant sweet,
they'll let go fucking bellies, you know,
they roll out the red carpet fuck head. You already paid for it.
They're looking for you to buy another jet. You know,
they probably do that with people who are really fat. You know what I mean?
When they show up, hey, just to let you know, fet,
Frank's showing up and he's going to the box match,
so let's bring in some extra chefs and add to the menu.
Who gives a fuck if no one else eats fried though,
this guy will eat enough fried dough to justify it, you know? No. All right,
whatever. Yeah, got to just joke. I'm making fun of fat people. This,
this isn't good. Oh, this is what you're probably thinking chief's bill.
Your energy's a little bit high for Thursday afternoon,
or maybe you're not thinking that.
Maybe I'm saying you think in that and I'm getting in your fucking head, right,
that we advertise this fill that they do. If they show one every five seconds,
rather than just getting annoyed on Internet, the Internet,
you're going to be like, Oh, you know what? I think I will fucking book.
I never watch him, which is really hypocritical because I have,
I have advertising on this podcast,
but you guys also have the option of just fast forwarding it, you know,
just still a pain in the ass. What I like about youtube, it's like,
you must watch this.
So what I always do is I hit fucking mute and then I just scroll down and I read
some of the comments and I just, just at the top of the screen,
I could see that things slide across and then I know it's fucking, oh,
you know why is about 20 years ago I was in a bar in,
this woman was in advertising that I met and she kept telling me that it works.
I'm gonna go, it doesn't work. Sometimes it annoys me and it makes it, she goes,
no, but it's in there. It works. It totally works. She just kept saying, no,
it works. It's just like, and I was so young and dumb. It's like, Bill,
this is the industry she's in. Okay,
why don't you just go tell somebody that their religion is wrong, you know?
Of course she's going to defend it. What she going to do? Say? Yeah,
it doesn't work. And then she's going to go to work in the morning.
But I was younger, you know, full head of fucking orange, red hair,
doing my best. Talking to the ladies down on Newbury Street. Right?
What do you say? They have fucking all black dress.
They're fucking goth looking chick. That's all I remember from back then.
All those fucking Goth,
look at chicks just fucking walking around down on Newbury Street,
that doc Martins and all that shit. He'd go over to daisy Buchanan's.
That was the meat market, right? That was the chicks that went to the gym.
Unlike the golf ones that were on Newbury street, there were all fucking sad,
you know, taking the weight of the world on their shoulders.
Those whores and days of you can is they didn't give a fuck.
They still don't give a fuck, you know,
and it made fucking starfish tattooed above the butt crack.
Just walking around. They didn't give a fuck. Um,
I walk in there with my fucking waist length leather jacket, my driving gloves.
Little did they know I stepped out of an 83 Ford fucking radar.
Two wheel drive, the extra log bed vinyl seats.
Five speed had a radio,
but somebody smashed the window and took it. Oh yeah ladies,
that's what your fucking your dream boat is arrived.
Okay.
Seinfeld like white sneakers, you know the high tops coming in.
You know dad jeans that were considered cool back then.
Maybe a sweatshirt that said a spirit or whatever the fuck his spirit. I Dunno.
It's a bad fucking image, but it's a true one.
I'll tell you what isn't a bad image. Did you guys watch a,
well I guess it is a veer of Dallas Stars Fan. Did you guys watch games?
Seven seven, seven seven. The St Louis Blues. Oh,
meet me in St Louis. Louis.
See You at the western conference finals.
Don't tell me the blues are choking. This is a different year.
Fucking St Louis Blues. I'm a repeat this.
The St Louis Blues had a seven in somebody else's building and not only did they
win, they gave them the old right. Damn Fred,
five to one. They were up five to nothing.
At one point they were leading the series three to two and they got to have
fucking, they got their lunch serve to them. They got their hats handed,
whatever you want to say in game six. Alright,
couldn't close them out and then they were going down to Dallas and I don't give
a fuck how big of of a St Louis Blues Fan you are,
you know God damn well you've been slapped in your, in your,
your fucking sports fan face too many times by the St Louis Blues is Dick.
Okay. They do it to every fucking year they get you excited. You Go, oh my God,
here we go. The playoffs right in the face and then it's fucking over.
You know what? Right.
So you probably thinking that they were going to fucking blow it against the
Black Cox and Holy Shit, they came back and they did it right.
So now they get another game, seven against the Dallas Stars.
And as much as you will say in your affair and you believe,
and you got your little trinkets and you sitting in your lucky chair in the back
of your head, you know what you go, and these are the blues.
They're going to fucking blow this.
And Jesus Christ did they give you guys an easy ride? Huh?
Three to nothing after one, then four to nothing.
And I know God damn well when you're rooting for a perennial fucking loser,
right? That always breaks your heart. You need five goals.
You need five goals to feel comfortable. You know,
I remember all of this shit back before we started winning every champion that
championship that exists. Um, yeah,
fucking red socks. I was comfortable with like a 12, 13 run lead,
but not if we were playing the Yankees.
And it was only the eighth inning prior to 2004. I was not comfortable with it.
So, um, what a fucking,
they just, they just went down and they just fucking,
just everything they throw out the net fucking went in.
Even what terrorists Sankoh's that weird his goal ever. He's trying to pass it.
He's almost parallel with the net and it did like the magic bullet JFK thing and
somehow went into the fucking back in the net and they took that away and I was
like, Oh God. And the fucking stars are flying up and down the hours.
They're stars at night, a big and Bright
Dallas right there. Fuck sorry. They're flying all over the fucking ice.
And I'm like, watch this. Here come the stars.
They're going to get the fucking equalize up right.
And then it's going to change the whole fucking shape of the game.
And then the fucking blue scare gave him the all right there, Fred,
two more fucking times, if I remember correctly.
And then all of a sudden it was fucking three to nothing and then four enough
and then five to nothing. And then the fucking stars scored a goal and I said,
our shit donate. Don't even tell me.
But then I just started doing the math going like, all right,
there's 10 minutes left. They need four goals.
They'd have to score one every two.
And a half fucking minutes and then like two and a half minutes went by and then
it's like I'm not doing the math. This is, this game is fucking over. And um,
I said the game was over when it was five to nothing.
But even though I said that I wouldn't have left like most of the fucking Douche
bag fans that were along the boards. Did you see how many fucking fans left?
They're not even fans.
Those are all the hookup costs that just went out to some VIP place afterwards.
They really made, they always make the, the,
the fans of the team look bad because I know the upper deck was still packed and
when the stars lost five to one,
everybody was left with standing on their feet applauding them.
I'm just letting stars Fan. I'm not judging your fan base by those fucking,
the hookup cons, the ones who know the people at the radio station,
the fucking whores that are then going to go to a steak house and try to bank
some 90 year old guy and fucking get his ATM pin number.
I'm not judging you guys by then. You know when the game's over,
they should pan up to the upper deck and see all the fucking diehards,
but I'm sad to see the stars go.
Obviously if they got some net minder problems in seg and didn't play the whole
fucking, he didn't play the whole playoffs and I'll tell you right now.
That's why the Bruins, that's why the Bruins got rid of them.
I'm going to make myself feel better. That's why we got rid of him. We know we,
oh yeah. He'll get you 30 40 goals during the regular season.
Where is he in the playoffs? Huh? What happened to him?
What happened to them?
Did he sprain one of his abs dancing with his shirt off and some fucking one of
those coyote ugly bars.
That's what the fuck he was doing when he was playing with us.
Oh,
that's true. That's what the rumor was. All right, here we go.
Yeah.
Well, let me see here. Yeah, Tyler Sagan injury.
What happened to him?
Well then if I can never going to say he's got a lower body in the waist area.
Injury, injured stars, Tyler Sagans makes progress, but not enough.
A lower body and Jew, they always say that it's always a lower body body injury.
That means you fucked up your shoulder. You know,
cause if they say what it is in these fucking animals, we'll actually uh,
actually go after Itso. Yeah. Tyler Sagan was a fucking no-show.
Tell you right now, Mark Messier. He would've got his ass out on the ice.
Oh yeah. You know that ty was saying, you know,
he's just a little fucking underwear model.
Okay.
I'm fucking with you. Well, my kid, I've been one time ice.
I fucking blocked a wrist shot and pick up hockey and I was limping for like
fucking 10 days. All right. That's the level of pussy I am.
So I'm just fucking around with Dallas Star fans here. Uh,
but congratulations to the blues tonight. Um, predators,
San Jose shot game seven,
and I don't know who I want to win. I like,
I love the predators cause I don't know, I just liked it. Fucking Unis and uh,
squish him, whatever. Get the into fucking hockey.
And there's something about this,
just something funny about the sharks choking every year and I don't know why,
but I just do not respect San Jose is a sports town. I just can't do it.
You know, I don't respect it cause none of you have the balls to live downtown.
Y'All live outside,
you know when your safe little high little houses on the high end are all made
out of ticky tech and more afraid to go downtown.
Oh my God. Is that a trolley?
You have a fucking trolley going through the center of town.
How much more quaint that they have to make it, I'm just fucking with you.
Downtown San Jose is no joke. Um,
in fact I remember a, the comedy club died,
somebody got shot and killed was fucking hilarious.
And then the comedians like F, I forget who the fuck it was that we put it.
They took the picture and they had like the whole Improv,
like marquee out front with the name of million, but the comedian, you know,
probably had some wacky photo there and then they just have a body with like a,
you know, God damn blanket over it. Um,
so I understand that. Um,
but then I was thinking what would be cool is if the sharks and the blues play
each other,
then somebody will finally sort of break their curse to get to the finals.
Um, I don't know if the sharks I've ever made a final,
and I don't know if the blues, I don't,
I can't remember the last time the blues did.
The last one I remember was the f was against the fucking Boston Bruins.
And I wasn't even a little really old enough to even have watched that.
They might've done it sometime in the nineties or, or in the two thousands,
but I was doing so much standup. I missed a lot of hockey back then.
So let's look this up saying Louis Blues
last finals. Yeah,
I don't think they've been in it in forever. Last finals appearances. All right.
Saint Louis Blues Financial Problems in playoff streak. 1970 1987 let's see,
list of blue seasons. I don't need this sheds too much here.
Stanley Cup champions. That's a big goose egg conference champion.
I think that's a goose egg too. No, it isn't because they've been to the finals
conference champion Stanley Cup champion. They won't have it. Come on.
You know what? Somebody just texted me this cause I don't want to fucking,
okay.
This is year by fucking years. Somebody actually looks at the shit.
Well actually aren't you looking at,
Oh this isn't what the fuck I wanted to look at.
Season was shortened due to strike in 94 95 to [inaudible].
You know, I thought I answered to ask the question pretty fucking clearly.
You know Saint Louis Blues Blues History.
Do I have to hit pause?
Okay,
does so and so going to smack a bitch. Remember that from fucking
Stanley Cup finals record. Here we go.
Saint Louis Blues Stanley Cup. Well, you know, I'd go fuck yourself. Fuck you.
Internet every once in a while.
And I thought you had all the answers or at least somebody making an attempt to
give me one. Isn't that how it works? So whatever.
I think I'm,
I think I almost want the sharks to win tonight because, uh, I dunno.
Just don't know how they do it with the fucking crazy Baird, you know,
like that'd be fun to watch. Oh, back and forth. They're blues predators.
He know. I don't know. That's almost like a subway series of a southern cities.
St Louis is a southern city.
They try to act like they're fucking from the Midwest. Yeah.
Go there and talk to some people. Jesus Christ.
Everybody there has got overalls. It's fucking unbelievable. You know,
and they got a Budweiser right in that little fucking pocket. I'm kidding.
They don't. All right. Um, oh by the way,
tomorrow. BOMP bomp
bomp bomp [inaudible]
okay.
Ooh. Like Jim has done tomorrow.
My Gym has done tomorrow and all freckles is going to turn into Joe fucking wait
, no,
I'm going to get my fucking ass in shape here cause I am in writer's room shape
right now and I'm dealing with CIA. Uh,
oh. Uh, um, which is almost gone.
Um, I'm uh,
taking my antiinflammatory drugs and doing all these fucking stretches at an
even. I have to go to a chiropractor. Um, but maybe I'll go,
I don't need it keeps telling me to go, so maybe I'll go. But anyways,
I got my fucking, um, I got my fucking atomic holds,
you know, I got my, uh, Mike Pegboard,
I've got a speed bag for Nia.
Um,
and then I got a, I got a bench, I get a fucking squat rack,
I get a pull up bar, I get a dip thing. And then I also got my climbing rope.
So there we go.
And all I got to do is take my dog for a walk around the block from my cardio.
Nothing fucking crazy that beaten up the knees of the feet, you know,
eat a salad every day. Like some fucking Yoga instructor, right?
Lay off the booze. That ain't happening. Lay off the cigars. That might happen.
I have a,
I'm smoking two in June and then I think I'm done until October.
And if I do that, then I'll only have smoked 10 for the year. And a,
I even think that's too many. I just think it's too many. I'd like to be,
I'd like to smoke six a year. This is what I'm going to do next year. All right.
It's gonna be, I'm smoking New Year's Day at the Rose Bowl.
I'm going to smoke with the Superbowl then I'm not smoking until my birthday in
June. And then I'm going to smoke once a year. I to a big college football game.
I'm going to smoke then. And then that sad. I smoked for a year.
I fucking enjoy this shit out of it, but I don't blow out my jaw,
my tongue on my throat or any of that stuff. I don't need that.
I don't need that my fucking life. So, um, speaking of which,
you should probably ask yourselves at this point. So bill,
what is the big college football game you go into this year? Tell you right now
Florida gators taken on the LSU taggers within brand new head coach.
You will it fucking walk or whoever the fuck he is. I don't know who he is. Um,
I'm beyond excited to go down there to the swamp. Um,
I actually really like love both those um, programs.
I mean I liked the Florida gators way back.
I would still wish that that orange helmet with the blue shirt,
which just fucking was the shit. Um,
somewhere along the line moving out to Los Angeles,
college football coming on so early and I had the time to watch it instead of
driving at gigs on Saturday, I, uh, got into LSU with the mad hatter,
his coach, and um, I don't know. That's going to be a tough one.
I don't know who to root for in that one. I want to go LSU,
but I don't want to be,
that contact goes to somebody's stadium and fucking roots against the home team.
I mean know it's not like I'm that fucking emotionally invested, um,
to be a Douche bag, you know,
I'm just going to go there and just hope it's a good game anyways. So, um,
I don't know where I'm going to be performing, but somewhere in that area, uh,
that area and um,
really fucking looking forward to that. So, um, I don't know.
So two more cigars in June and then I'm going to be done for awhile. Allegedly.
Yeah. Right. Belt. Like you're going to go to fucking Europe.
They're going to just have any Cuban cigar you want,
you're not going to go in and smoke one,
but if I'm over there for 10 days and I just smoke one, that's okay. Right. Um,
all right, let's uh, let's read a little bit of advertising here. Alright. Oh,
it's our old friends here. Club Debbie convenience club. Debbie,
do you have any oil? I want it. I want your oil. Come on me.
Delivers wine straight to your door. Personalized.
We send you wine that is personalized to your, uh,
palate slash tastes. Through our Palette quiz,
our recommendations become an even more personal,
become even more personalized with every bottle you rate.
We work with top wine makers and growers from around the world world,
world, world directly to make all of our wine. Um,
high quality and value are $13 bottle would normally retail for 20 bucks.
That probably doesn't sound like a lot of big difference until you do the
percentage, you know what I mean?
Okay.
I mean five times 20 is $100 five times 13 is this 65,
um, no risk.
You choose the type and quality of bottles with no membership fee or
cancellation fee and a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
A creative,
we partner with local artists to develop wine labels that are unique works of
art right now at Club Debbie sedan brought it on himself.
Is offering listeners $20 off your first order when you go to clamp
gibeah.com/burr and it gets even, yeah. Yeah.
I know you all hate paying for shipping. So club Debbie,
a daddy loves me more than jeep.
We'll have actually pay for your shipping on orders of four bottles or more.
So take something off your to do list.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr to get $20 off your first order right
now. That's club debbie.com/. Burn. All right, zip.
Are you hiring? Are you, are you [inaudible]?
Um, I just went, what's his face in breakfast club? Do you know why I'm here,
dude? Are you hiring? Are you,
do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates? Well,
do you Johnny? Oh, do you?
Posting your job in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your jobs on all the top job sites and now you can,
um, with ziprecruiter.com you can post your jobs to 100 plus job sites,
including social media networks like Facebook and Twitter,
all with only one single click.
Find candidates in any city for any industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch all of your qualified candidates roll in right to
Daddy. Come to Daddy, baby into ZipRecruiter's. Easy to use. Interface.
No juggling emails or calls to your office. No pain in the ass.
Quickly screen candidates, rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has been used by over 800,000 businesses.
And right now listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] that ziprecruiter.com/burr one more time.
Try It for free. Go to ziprecruiter.com/bar hey, if you're looking for a job,
I bet there's a way to upload your resume to Zip [inaudible].
All right, track or, um,
tracker, whether the hell's the top of this copy right smack,
Chaz SMAD phones, smart homes.
Technology has made everything wicked, Matt.
But losing stuff still makes people feel really stupid.
No tracker makes losing things a thing of the past. Well, Gee, Bill,
how the fuck does it work? Well, I'll tell you. Trackers, a coin size device,
does that locates misplaced keys, wallets, bags, computers,
anything in seconds? Uh,
just put track or on a scarecrow and you're like, oh, there's where I put it.
Wait, they don't move. Just put tracker onto your smartphone,
attach it to anything and find his precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that easy. Lose your phone,
press the button on track or your phone rings even when it's on silent with over
1.5 million devices tracker has the largest crowd gps network in the world world
world world, so you, your lost items shows up on a map.
Even if it's miles away, never lose anything.
Again with tracker listeners to this show,
get a special discount of 30% off your entire order.
Go to the tracker.com and enter Promo Code Burr.
The hardest single lever have to do is find their website now snort.
Go to tracker.com right now and enter the Promo code birth for 30% off your
entire order. Again, that's tracker.com Promo Code Bar.
You can't tell me some stockers not gonna throw that in the book bag of some
fucking dude. You know,
fucking try and bust him doing some shit and I don't know, score big everybody.
You're paying too much. You're paying too much for tickets between the markups.
And last minute convenience challenges, even printed home fees.
Are you kidding me? Or what? Use end up you end use.
You end up paying court side prices for nosebleeds seats score big is here to
change that.
Did you know that 40% of all live event tickets go on sold and did you know that
there's a place to get these seats at huge savings? It's called score.
Big Score.
Big works directly with your favorite teams and artists to get their unsold
seats at unpublished prices only with ScoreBig.
Can you name a ticket price and be guaranteed to pay below box office up to 60%
off. Here's what you do. One,
go to score big.com or download the new score big app for your iPhone and find
the event and seats.
You want to make an offer for score Biggs name and ticket price feature. Three,
get an instant answer and save up to 60% on your tickets for.
Take Your Dick out and say, I've got it again. No, it's not.
Never any fees and shipping is always free.
You can count on unbeatable prices and great seats.
And when you're in great seats,
you actually enjoy the game or show all the more.
Next time you go see any game or show,
go to score big first and see how much you can save for the easiest way to save
on tickets. Download the new score,
big app for your iPhone and to Promo Code [inaudible] at the checkout.
And you'll save an extra $20 off your first ticket purchase. No iPhone,
no problem. Get $20 off online.
two@scorebigdotcomthatscorebig.com, Promo Code Bar Score,
[inaudible] dot com Promo Code Berg. Alright,
let's talk attempted suicides here, shall we? Um,
yesterday a man in a,
a green Celtics sweatshirt climbed up the KT,
La, um, TV tower. And, um,
interestingly enough, we're writing efforts for family not too far away.
So we saw the helicopters but couldn't see the guy. And, um,
so out here, you know, in La, they show everything live on the news,
except now when they think somebody's gonna die. So you know,
cause a long time ago they showed guy who was trying to kill
himself and he tried to light himself on fire and like a Suzuki Samurai,
it didn't work. And then he got out of the fucking car,
he had a fucking 12 gauge shotgun, he got on his knees,
put it under his fucking Chin and blew his fucking head off on TV.
And like kids were home from school.
It happened at like three 30 in the afternoon. So like,
we can't do that shit anymore. Right?
So what do we do?
We put on periscope and God knows there's people fucking filming this shit and
um, the dudes up there, so immediately, by the way, he did, he doesn't die.
I wouldn't be doing this if the guy died. He's fucking up there. Right.
And, um,
which I think is all a big sign saying that Kevin Durant is going to come to the
Celtics. He's leaving Oklahoma. All right.
He's had enough of you wholesome, racist people out there.
He would like to perform in front of some unwholesome racist people in Boston.
That's what I feel. Um, anyways,
so the guys climbed up the Katy La Tower, they're trying to get them down.
They've got a couple of fucking air mattresses or whatever the fuck they put
down there. And he climbs up and over the five. And it was amazing.
The guy was up there for three fucking hours and I gotta tell Ya,
I'd be lying to you if I didn't start thinking about survivor because it really
seemed like one of their challenges where you always have to stand on like a
fucking, I dunno, like a bamboo pole with one foot, you know,
balance in a tea cup on your head. It kind of seemed like that after awhile.
Like how the fuck would somebody stay up there that long?
And he was up there smoking cigarettes and taking phone calls and shit.
And I'm all I could think was okay.
I was, if I was going to kill myself, I would never jump off something.
You know what I mean?
There's too much time to think about what you just did on the way down.
Right. This just, and it's just no way I even know it's right.
The old right there, Fred. It's just immediately fucking over. It's just the,
the, the, the fucking mess. You know? It's like, come on man. You know?
Okay.
Basically not something, he's got to clean it. That's,
that's the last thing you do.
Everybody said that you're dead and then you leave a giant fucking mess.
Somebody's got to come over there with a fucking wet vac and try to clean up the
Goddamn Stina. God knows, you know when you jump off of something,
it's usually not your house. You know, it's,
nobody really has a house big enough to jump off of them. Die.
They usually land in the grass, right?
So all you do is just break your fucking legs with some shit and separate your
fucking shoulder.
I'm not saying you can't jump off a house and die,
but I'm just saying, you know, you want to make sure you die,
which means you're going to go to someplace that's a little higher up,
some sort of public structure with concrete, and there's people walking by,
right? They just, it's just such a selfish fucking way to do it, right?
People coming up the Goddamn street, you know, hey,
I'm so excited to go see, um, everybody wants some,
I wasn't alive in the 80s, but I'd like to see Hollywood's version of it, right?
It just like these last two weeks, it's just been so wonder if the,
it's just all over the fucking place. So anyway,
I just get home. And then the worst part is if you jump in,
you actually fucking live. You know what I mean? And then you have,
your feet are pointed in every fucking direction except the way they're supposed
to, you know, and then you've got to go around being the inspirational speaker,
you know, with a specially designed fucking wheelchair, you know,
for somebody who has feet, you know, that point in every fucking duro.
I don't know, some sort of, I think he, at that point they just said yes,
they will. Yan like Hannibal Lecter. And then you gotta be like,
just standing there, you know, with your custom sneakers,
talking to some fucking group of people about, you know,
why you have so much Deloitte,
a fucking way to find out that he got so much to live for. Um,
it's never the fucking answer. You know what I mean?
Cause it's bad.
Think about somebody depressed in St Louis is bad as their fucking life is
the Saint Louis Blues made the Western Conference fucking finals. I mean, yeah,
if you killed yourself, you wouldn't have seen that. You know?
And then you can't go down to the bar.
Everybody's in a good mood and all of a sudden,
some hot chick with the St Louis Blues t-shirt tied off at the fucking navel
comes over, gives you a hug. You're like, oh wow. That's what life's all about.
Getting a hug from a hot chick and going home and rubbing one out to her. Ah,
I can't believe I almost jumped off that fucking distillery.
You know what I'm trying to say is don't fuck. I can always don't kill yourself.
All right, this has been a public service announcement.
I'm going to lie to you if I didn't fucking look up.
Worst ways to kill yourself.
I've found this fucking website and the unfortunate thing was the person tried
to be funny rather than just presenting them.
They tried to put their own funny spin on it like I'm about to write. Um,
alright. Seven most unusual ways to kill yourself.
Um, all right. Number one, this guy tried to kill himself by eating a bible.
The doctor said, uh,
I was not strong enough to pull the object out of the guy's throat. Um,
I don't believe that that's true. I don't believe somebody ate a Bible.
I think that's one of those, uh, not the creationists,
the other fucking people. What's the other people there? I don't fucking know.
If you don't believe in creationism, you believe in what a big bang ism person.
I don't fucking know. Anyways, the next one,
a guy killed himself in prison by stuffing toilet paper down his throat.
That's how bad prison is. You know what I mean? And, uh, you know,
if you have a solid Shawshank redemption, that seems like the, the,
it seems the better way to go in a more pleasing thing to have in an orifice.
Uh, sorry, number five,
this guy in Singapore worked at the zoo wanting to kill himself.
Natural Way to do it.
Why take a bunch of sleeping pills and go peacefully when you can walk into the
tiger cage. I bet that's nice and quick to, you know, I've always wanted a pet,
a tiger too,
so I think he could get one quick petted before he fucking grabbed you by your
throat. Gave you a nice shake. You just go to,
it's like getting put into the sleeper Holt by one of the UFC guys,
except they would do it with their mouth. Um, number four,
uh, this woman drank Draino and p. That's disgusting. That's not a funny one.
Here's the one. A guide to capitated himself.
He got into an Austin Martin tied a rope around his neck, you know,
did a burnout. Woo. That's it.
Um, I guess he was trying to get revenge on his wife.
I don't know how that works. You know what I mean?
Cause it was a lot of the cleaners today. I don't,
you could literally bleed out in a car like that and they can,
they can get me enough. You ever see that pimp my ride.
They could take that Austin Martin down there in a fucking day.
They had all the materials. They could take that interior,
put it back in and no one would ever know that you ripped your fucking head off.
Although I wonder what happened to the car. So he just kept going.
That's another one.
Now what if someone was coming up the street doing the fucking paper route?
No one does a paper anymore. It's an adult job. All right.
I'm just, one guy tried to kill himself.
He had to shoot himself three fucking times. That's not funny.
Then another guy went out into the woods.
He handcuffed himself to a tree and then threw the fucking key away and then
they could tell that he struggled to try to free himself.
See that's why you never do it.
Nobody ever fucking killed themselves except for a guy in jail. We just like, I,
I might just spend the rest of my life fighting off fucking people trying to
stab me and fuck me. I mean, that's when you got it. That's what God's like.
All right, I get it. I get it. No worries. Die. You don't got to explain it.
Come on in. Come on at. Um,
you did your time. All right. I can't end on suicide. All right,
let's go with a prediction here. Alright. Um,
tonight having watched zero predators or San Jose sharks games this year,
having watched maybe three minutes of that entire series,
I can tell you without a shadow of a doubt,
no, I can't pay. I've not seen that. I know.
I'm trying to close my eyes and see the winner that I believe that the winner of
tonight's gay, it's gonna be
okay.
I'm going to say the predators.
And the whole reason why I'm saying the president predators is because the St
Louis Blues were the away team and they want in a two home gonna lose a game
seven on back to back nights. Okay?
And that's the type of philosophy right there.
Why Vegas always wins because there's not an ounce of intelligence in what I
just said. All right. I'm picking the predators. That's it. All right. Oh,
freckles is test to go to the a as to go to work. And uh,
my Jim's going to be finished tomorrow, so starting Saturday,
all Billy beefcake will be coming to be coming to a town near you with my
overdeveloped freckled pecks right. All of that type of shit.
My sciatica is going to be cured by then. Uh,
I just don't sit down anymore. You know, the,
of course that's going to lead to some sort of feet problem. But, um, anyways,
thank you for listening as always. And um,
thank you for all the great emails I got on Monday.
I'm glad you guys enjoy when my wife comes on and fucking shits on me.
You know, I, I actually like it too. It makes me laugh.
I enjoy it even though she's a pain in the ass. Uh, all right, that's it.
So please enjoy the music and we'll get,
give you another half hour of a classic podcast from a,
from a year gone by in a place, I can't remember.
[inaudible]
Hey, what's going on? It's still okay.
It's the Monday morning podcast that I am doing on a Tuesday at 1120 in the
morning, east coast time.
Fucking believe that was on me slipping. You know,
no excuse. Actually, I do have an excuse.
It was my girlfriend's birthday yesterday. So, uh,
I was being a great boyfriend,
paying attention to her and someone had to suffer. You know what I mean?
It's like a, someone always feels left out, man.
How much you try to pay attention.
My kid and I never had a threesome before. I couldn't have one once.
I think twice.
The first time I didn't realize that it was going down.
I was so young and stupid. I was actually sitting there and I was thinking,
why won't her roommate leave? You know, the fuck.
And it wasn't until like literally seven years later I went, oh wait a minute.
She wasn't leaving cause fuck.
And then the other time, uh,
it was right there on the table and, uh,
one girl was absolutely gorgeous and the other one,
uh, was not gorgeous. Let's put it that way,
was so not gorgeous that she eclipse the beauty of the other one,
you know, so, so they, you'd go, hey,
you learned something about me right off the damn bat. Okay.
Oh well this is what we're going to do this week on the podcast.
If you guys are new to this shit. A new to my page. Um,
I didn't want to use every God damn week and people asked me questions and I try
to answer them. And other than that, I babble.
I give you information about my life and uh,
and that's it. I'm fucking out of it. All right. I drank last night. Okay.
I was celebrating connection,
went to this God damn restaurant in New York who went to Bible and I'm a big fan
of Mario Batali, but I like Lupa better. Baba was just too,
it was too, uh, what, uh,
my palate was not sophisticated enough. Alright.
I'll take the blame chooses Christ.
It was like regular dishes with shit you'd never eat.
I had beef cheek, Ravioli. Yeah.
We want you to fucking take that in for a minute. All right. And they had,
you know, they had like pheasants face fucking Lasagna, you know,
it was always like half what you would heard of like goose liver,
a fucking souffle. So I dunno,
it was, they was good. But a Lupa is the shift.
That's the one that I liked that's got like a fucking, you know,
regular animals,
body parts that you eat mixed in with fucking a Rigatoni.
Oh, what the fuck are you going to do? You know, you try shit.
You know, she wanted to go there. I fucking took her there. And uh,
that's what happened. I had two cupcakes for breakfast.
What you think about that?
It was sitting there leftover from the party and I said,
that's a great way to start my day.
Let me give myself 9,000 calories of straight sugar was unreal.
It was like I did an eight ball.
That's where I ate the two cupcakes for 20 minutes.
I was just sitting there thinking, how fucking great I wasn't. I'm like,
I'm fucking awesome. I could do anything.
I want a fucking the greatest.
And 20 minutes later when the sugar started wearing off, oh my God.
I started pulling the drapes closed, laying in here like, uh, I dunno.
I Dunno. Don't ever start your day with fucking two, two cupcakes.
After had a beef.
She fucking Ravioli beef cheek. I was like, cheek like the ass.
You being cute. They're like, no, they actually know what,
I didn't have the fucking balls to ask him.
I didn't want to know how I was eating somebodies face meeting. A Yak face.
Yeah. Let me get the Yak taint a red goon. Um,
let's continue with the, uh, the continuing story of American Airlines.
If you listened to my, uh, my podcast last week, uh,
these cheap ass motherfuckers at American Airlines, uh, you know,
they allegate around the fucking food up in first class. You know what I mean?
They had 20 people in First Class and they made five omelets.
And next thing you know, I was eating a bowl of total open Nebraska.
Actually, no, that's not what happened. Just to give you the quick synopsis,
I said, Fuck you and your honeycomb cereal.
This is first class and I don't get a Goddamn Mama. I don't want anything.
I said all of that with a little less anger and no curses.
So a few seconds later the guy came back, all of a sudden he magically,
he has an Omelette and I'm like, where did you get that?
And he informed me that the pilots said he already ate so I could have his
omelet. And I was like, I don't want his fucking Omelet. I want my omelet.
All right. I don't want to starve. And pilot, you know,
passing out up there, seeing bogeys leaning forward on the Goddamn yoke,
whatever you call it. All right.
So I sent them a letter and this is the letter that they sent back to me and I
swear to God, you know,
back in the day if something like this ever happened and you actually wrote a
letter, you prefer at least they give you a free airline ticket. And I'm,
when I say back in the day,
I mean like 2005 2006 now they don't give a shit.
They just keep apologizing profusely.
This is this dumb ass letter they sent back to me.
I'm only going to read you part of it because they just keep saying the same
thing over and over again. Okay. Let me, I got the hiccups.
I think I have sugar hiccups from stuffing down to cupcakes.
Hang on a second. As from service. Hello? Yeah,
I'm going to check out about a like 15 minutes. Okay.
Thank you Jesus. They didn't say anything. She said hello?
I said, yeah, I'm going to check out 15 minutes. At which point she could,
could've said okay for older Ley, you know, but no,
she just closes the door.
Okay.
All right. Okay. Here's the fucking, uh, oh. What do we got here? This is the,
okay. This isn't, this is the letter that American Airlines sent me. Okay,
dear Mr. Burke, thank you for contacting American Airlines.
It's our privilege to respond to your message. Okay? First of all,
right there. They already pissed me off. Okay. Don't,
don't start with off with your fucking stock line,
like your Jackie Gleason, you know, thank you for writing us in a way we go,
you know, a little shoving off the buffalo. Uh, okay.
I'm very sorry to hear of your disappointment with us and regret that you did
not receive your preferred entree when you traveled with us in the first class
cabin. Uh,
CLS soulless assists because we want your travel experience or improving premium
cabins to be truly something special.
We do our best to cater our entree selections so that we can serve each customer
the entree they prefer. This is the part which is just complete bullshit.
Okay. They want to make sure that they serve the entree that I prefer. You know?
Yeah. You can do that. Bringing up fucking eggs on the flight.
This is what they write to do.
So we determine which entrees are selected most often.
It's often and provision accordingly. That's,
that's such fucking bullshit. I mean,
but then they watched Jurassic Park when Jeff Goldbloom did his little rant
about chaos theory.
You think cause you take 10 flights or a hundred flights and you figure out,
oh you know seven people want the Omelet
and you know nine people want something else. That's such bullshit.
First of all, nobody wants to fucking cereal.
Someone wants cereal in first class. Okay,
you fucking dropped $1,500 or whatever the hell is 800 $1,500 on ticket.
You want something of substance. I'm sick of bitching about this.
Oh I know it was in the end of it.
I ended up flying fucking a middle seat to fucking Dallas and all I got was $150
voucher which will pay for one third.
They didn't give me anything Mr. Barrier,
we are not unmindful of the inconvenience of you. Well,
how the fuck would you be on mindful? I wrote you a God damn letter.
As hard as we are trying to deliver on respecting your time by operating our
flights as scheduled, it just wasn't possible this time. Again,
we apologize for the disruption of your travel plans. We're not giving you shit.
Please slide with us again soon.
We'll do our best to get you to your destination as planned.
Really, you're going to do your best. That's what you can give me.
American Airlines. Well, Gee, you know, we're going to try.
That's a comforting attitude to have when they're going to be flying it fucking
36,000 feet off the goddamn ground. Oh, do I sound like a client this week?
So that's basically it. That's, that's the, uh,
the next level that they've taken it to where it used to be like, okay,
we fuck you over. And the stewardess gives you a hand job. You know,
that was 1975. And in the 80s, it was, you know,
we'll give you a free ticket and a skinny Michael J. Fox tie. But those things,
you know,
when you had the little spiked out mullet and they had lasted for a good 20
years and somewhere in the last four or five years, it became a,
we're going to fuck you over and back. Go Fuck Yourself.
What do think about that? Go Fuck Yourself.
[inaudible]
299 other people on the plane that didn't fit in complaint. What do you do?
Take the train. It's going to take him nine days to get to New York.
Go Fuck Yourself. Do you know you're coming back? It's just eggs.
You know of yourself. Know what?
They got me over God damn barrel sons of bitches. What am I going to do?
Fly ATA, you know Nina fucking
okay.
Yeah, I dunno what in a goddamn chicken. I'm actually,
I think ATA recently went out of business.
You have a flying airline and then you know, you're like, Eh, you know,
it was kind of weird flight and you know, there was a crack in the uh,
inner window actually that happened to be on ATA. One of the windows, you know,
they got like the, they got the, the double pane of glass, they got the,
the one on the outside,
the outside of the plane and then they have the one on the inside,
the extra level one. And that one was cracked.
And I believe it was a little bit of water in there. And I said to the, uh,
to the students, I was like, a woman,
there's a fucking crack in the God damn window over here.
I'm afraid I'm going to get sucked out once we get above 6,000 feet. She said,
it's like [inaudible] class,
you know, so I didn't feel bad when they went out of business.
Now I kind of feel bad because now there's no, there's no other option.
I guess that's my other option.
Do I sit there and I take it on American Airlines and they go, go fuck yourself.
All right, we're going to give you a brand muffin.
I hope you brought some water.
Or I fly another airline when their inner window was cracked and no one thinks
it's a concern. Painter winters crack. Well, that's,
that's why we got two of them. All right.
This podcast is just a cluster. Fuck.
Let's get to some podcast questions that I didn't even,
I didn't even have the time to fucking look at this week. Actually.
That's not true. I went to look at them and somebody,
I don't know what's going on with my myspace page.
I don't know if anybody else has had this problem. But, uh,
I ended up able to really add anybody for about a year, you know,
every couple of days they'll get about 45 requests, I'll accept them.
And then a day later I have 47 people taken off my page. And it's like,
really? We're all those people spammers. I don't know what's going on. So, uh,
I'm having somebody look into my account. The only question I can remember,
I can't even remember if it was something about fucking, uh,
you know, what movies do I find scary? Um, well, you know what,
if you turned my flight on American Airlines into a movie,
I would've found that fucking scary. Um, what movies do I find scary?
Anything that involves a crazy woman? Um,
I think the scariest movies when I first got cable in the early eighties,
when I had a tight jeans and, uh,
pony high tops that just met the bottom of my jeans and no one complained
because somehow you could get away with that back then. Um, I remember, uh,
the first Friday the 13th, when Jason came up out of the lake,
that scared the shit out of me. And there was another one. Here's,
here's one for you. Okay. I've got a podcast question for you guys.
There was a movie I saw late night cable and I can't remember what the fuck it
was,
but it somehow there was somebody skating across the pond in slow motion with an
ax. And I believe for some reason the, uh,
the monster I'm picturing is, is from that. I know this isn't it,
but the picture in my mind is, uh,
what does that monster book where the wild things that I remember what those
monsters look like in my memory.
That's what the monster look like skating across the fucking lake. Uh,
and I know it isn't that, but I know somebody, what do you,
what am I 14 listeners out there has to be a fucking horror or a film,
uh, whatever. The,
what do you call someone's really in a horror films like Geek. Yeah, exactly.
A horror film. Fucking Dick. There was that one and a,
there was another one I was just thinking of and I just sat up and I can't
remember it. I'm getting a fucking age.
I literally just moved my brain a little bit. The thought just went away.
Wait a second. What the fuck was I just thinking? Let me lay back down.
Let me see what would come back to me. Okay.
I was talking about we got to go back in time. You know I was talking. Okay.
The lake, while things are,
see that's how my brain works. It works linear. Once I go past the moment, I,
I can't go back. It's like a fucking traffic jam.
What the fuck was I trying to think of? Ah,
Shit. I don't know. Oh, I got it. Bam. There we go. Um,
dark night or the scare crow. I liked the old horror movies.
Okay. This is what, you know what I don't like about new horror movies fit they,
that CGI shit. They,
they can do so much insane stuff with computers that they forgot how to build
suspense. The old ones they used, they used to build it up.
They used to build up the moment where the monster was going to jump out at you
because they had to because it was just a guy in a rubber fucking suit.
You know what I mean? But now that they can, they can,
you know they can make it look like God still is stepping on New York.
They forgot how to build, dispense.
That's what I don't like about fucking horror movies now. And that's a,
I think Japanese,
I dunno everybody over in Asia seems to know how to fucking do that.
But nobody over here does even like, like, like thrillers,
whatever the fuck it, whatever a goddamn thriller is like take that,
that movie a perfect storm. They had that goddamn big wave.
That's all they showed in the trailer.
So everybody goes out to run out and see it and then they don't develop any of
the goddamn characters because the point that I don't give a fuck about anybody
in the movie. So by the end of the movie,
I'm actually praying for the wave.
I can't wait for them to kill George Clooney and Mark Walberg and all those
other guys.
Cause I don't give a fuck about their characters cause if they haven't done
anything to make me give a fuck,
they just had a couple of people speaking Boston accent and you stick them on a
tugboat and I'm supposed to give a shit.
They gonna die trying to get lobster. Um,
I'm just in a bad mood. I'm in a bad fucking mood today. I'm like,
you know what it is,
is the gun and don't ever start your day with two fucking cupcakes.
It seems like such a great, you know, it's such a great idea, you know, like,
oh, I'm eight years old. This is what you'd want to do.
But your parents never loved you, you know? And now I'm 39 and 51 weeks.
And finally the dream that I thought was going to happen,
you know, oh it did happen. And then it doesn't play out. Right. Oh my God.
How did I forget this shit?
I know I forgot it because I have fucking two cupcakes with the sugar in my
brain. I actually had a crazy week. How crazy was it bill?
Um, I flew into New York on Wednesday. I did okay. And Anthony Opening,
Anthony Opie and Anthony show Thursday morning.
Then I did my show at Caroline's in New York Thursday night.
I got up Friday morning, got on a plane, flew back to la.
I did the guys' choice awards on a SPITV men,
all these famous people. They were all cool. I had a great time.
I met Nikki six,
I was way more thrilled and the after party was at the fucking playboy mansion.
And I know what you're thinking. Oh my God, playboy is fucking mentioned.
That must've been unbelievable. Um, I quickly realized when I got there,
there's two kinds of parties at the playboy mentioned. There's the,
your famous and you can come by Wednesday afternoon and actually meet the broads
that are in the magazine.
And then there's the one that I went to where it's like, yeah,
why don't you guys all just stand on my, in my backyard?
I literally thought I was going to show up to the mansion, right.
Was going to be like me and eight other people. And just, you know,
for playboy bunnies eats just rubbing on my chest. Hey there, big boy.
I heard you're a comedian now. They just had, they had the,
it was definitely the beat team, a playboy bunny, you know,
they had little bunny suits on and the rabbit ears, the,
let me tell you something. They were, uh,
they were grade a hooter girls and he could tell there was three of them who
were clearly being paid to frolic in the pool.
And any girl with bunny ears had like nine guys around her was a fucking sausage
fest. And this is the funny thing. Nobody was hitting on them.
They was standing there with the fucking cameras out,
taking pictures like, uh,
like they were Disneyland and they ran into Donald Duck or something.
It was pathetic. And uh, you know, you have no,
was roped off with his three fucking girlfriends, 83 years old man guy.
It was the shit that was the only thing I wanted to do.
I just want to go in there and shake his hand and, uh,
then immediately stick my hand in bleach to get the unbelievable smell of 50
years of pussy off of my hand. And, uh, then fly back.
But he was busy. I understand. He had to meet, uh, famous fucking people.
So, uh, but still still was shit. And then I flew back the next day,
six in the fucking morning. I landed in New York at about four 30. I got my bag,
I went over to Caroline's and I did three fucking shows, you know,
and then I went out drinking afterwards.
And that's the kind of thing that leads you to be in a country mood on a Tuesday
morning. You know, I did all of that and then I ate two cupcakes. All right.
So don't even question my fucking mood. All right. So, um,
so there you go. That was my week, Huh? Went to a party at the playboy mansion.
I did stand up on my first award show. When is it going to be at you? Ask why.
I'll tell ya, it's going to be on our June 22nd. Um,
and I had a great time doing the set, even though, uh,
most of the crowd was a pay crowd, you know, good looking people,
hot chicks texting each other. And I, God, what,
when this is going to be our bar.
It's like [inaudible] I wanna blow Jeremy Pittman.
I'm going to be on June 22nd, and this week coming up this week,
I'm going to be at a good night's comedy club in Raleigh,
North Carolina. You can go to bill.com and get all the fucking information.
And uh, later on this month, I'm going to be the punchline in Atlanta,
hot Atlanta, the brothers call it, and a,
I think that date is June 19th or something like that. I don't fucking know.
I can't get on this hotel internet and I have to check out in 19 fucking
minutes. So I gotta go apologize for a,
the podcast being a day late and, uh, forgive my continuous on this podcast.
I'm going to blame it on the sugar from the two.
What a fucking half a fag, Huh? Starts the day with two cupcakes.
So they call me Billy two cupcakes. Billy cupcake. All right,
you guys have a good week. Please keep the podcast questions common.
Sorry about this week, man. I had somebody,
I don't know what's going on with my fucking page or please keep them calm and,
and, uh,
let people know about my podcast and thanks to everybody came out to my shows in
May in Philadelphia, Chicago, and a in New York City.
All right, you guys all have a good week. I'll talk to you later. Bye.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].